a central theme running through all of
machiavelli's writings
is fortune and the vicissitudes of
fortune fortune he says
is what rules the world around us but
she it's always he always imagines her
as a woman she is very unpredictable and
very capricious you never know when
she's going to rise you up to the
highest heights
when she's going to knock you down on
your knees
why is an italian man from the 15th
century worth writing about
um i think there are at least two good
reasons
for that on the one hand
machiavelli has exerted
an influence over the development of
western political thought
like very few others
there are not many discussions about
real politics the nature of rulership
uh the role of virtue or the lack
thereof in public life which did not at
some point
come back to machiavelli in his writings
the second reason is closely connected
with that
when we think of machiavelli it's quite
natural for us to think of
the adjective machiavellian that's to
say
someone who is shrewd cunning a little
bit amoral willing to do
things that they probably shouldn't do
in other areas of life
and that association which i'm sure
we'll discuss in in further detail later
on in the show
um has often colored the way we perceive
the man
his life however uh is quite different
or gives us a quite different
idea of uh it all gives us quite
different depression
um although he often did things which
were
um questionable he was far from being
this infallible political genius
uh that we may think of uh in actual
fact
uh he was a very human person
a flawed personality who was often
getting things
wrong he was often finding himself in
the wrong place at the wrong time doing
the wrong thing with the wrong
people and getting found out um so i
think
yeah uh on the one hand we should look
at machiavelli from the point of view of
his
uh enduring relevance the idea of
relevance as a criterion of his type of
study
for his relevance to to political
discourse on the other hand
because of the extent of which his life
does
so jars with that a little bit it seems
like some of the
established thought was that he was kind
of born
with this immutable characteristics
these
amazing political thinker and yet upon
reading about his life it seems like he
kind of blunders and blunders and
slowly gets less worse and less worse
and less worse and then eventually ends
up at
some degree of capability
he is always making blunders uh from the
beginning of his political career
to the last moment he is always getting
things
wrong it doesn't sit that's not to say
he doesn't get a lot of things right
but he is always making miscalculations
he's better i think
on paper than he is in his own political
career
um but it is certainly true that because
of machiavelli's enduring uh resonance
uh
within the field of political thought or
historical thought
um many people even today um have been
inclined to believe that he was born
um you know uh like athena from the head
of
uh the of the philosophy gods
um with this great insight and it is
i mean i'm not saying it's it's
completely wrong
because one can detect the genesis of
his ideas
in his thinking from a comparatively
early date but it is
i think mistaken to believe that he was
a man without flaws without
personal failings without
problems and difficulties but for me as
i hope i've shown in the book that makes
him
all the more relatable all the more
engaging and personable i often say that
you know i uh there are very few
political thinkers in the world that i'd
like to go through
a pint with but machiavelli's certainly
one of them
is that why he's still notorious today
then
why is it there's lots of renaissance
figures that could have been
still used in common parliament i mean
machiavellianism
his surname has become a
entire topic within its own right why is
he so notorious
well um machiavelli's uh
significance um as a political thinker
and his unfortunate reputation stems
from
the fact that he broke quite
significantly in many respects
um with earlier traditions of political
thought
particularly with earlier ideas of
worship um
prior to machiavelli's birth it was
uh quite common to believe that uh
princes who wish to rule properly
and to remain in power should do so by
acting virtuously and virtue was
understood in
um a mixture of kind of stoic and
christian terms
that's to say it was believed that ruler
should evince those virtues which we
should all
manifest in our lives we should be
honest they should be decent they should
be prudent
they should be wise continent etc etc
they should
um act always with justice um
machiavelli for very pragmatic reasons
thinks that
while this might be a very good approach
to adopt as a private citizen
he thinks that experiences showed that
in practice
it's not such a good idea in fact
in times of turbulence such as those
which in which he was living
um it can actually be disadvantaged to
act honestly
or with generosity or with uh
mercy or compassion etc so in the prince
um his most famous
work i should say historious work he
suggests that it is a
prince who wishes to stay in power
should as well as having
um an independent military force of his
own citizens
he should um be uh
parsimonious rather generous he should
be
um cruel rather than compassionate um
likely does say that if he can make
himself loved with people that's a
lovely thing
but love is a less reliable
sentiment uh as a basis for political
power
than uh fear um
better okay to be ready to be dishonest
and honest
um etc etc um
so machiavelli is breaking uh with this
early tradition in saying that
a prince needs to act in a way that is
um
not always in conformity with
traditional ideas of virtue or
of of ethical goodness he wasn't i
should stress
the absolute first uh to make these
points
um when at the very early on in his
career
in 1499 florence
sacks and arrests one of its leading
military commanders a guy called paulo
vitelli
and palo vitelli is responsible for
leading a campaign to recapture peace
which is rebelled against plants it'll
be before for whatever reason
vitelli throws away a golden opportunity
to capture visa
and the florentines attribute this
either to incompetence or
treachery and so they arrest him and
they bring him for trial to france
and there's a big debate
about whether he should just be executed
straight off
even though there are doubts about his
guilt or whether you know you should
give him the benefit of the doubt
and there are very good article powerful
arguments made in the councils
that while an individual
private individual should act with
compassion and understanding and justice
things are different for a state a state
should act
in such a way that it preserves its own
interest
and so they decide to execute vitelli
and we can see in this idea this idea of
reason of state later becomes known
that um the state should follow a
different set of moral precepts to
private individuals an
early um foretaste of ideas that
machiavelli is going to develop
more fully and in the prince he really
works out all the implications of this
unfortunately um well i should say he's
writing against as i said
earlier a very very very specific set of
political circumstances um when he's
writing
um he's lost his job uh florence
has changed hands from being a republic
it's now gone back into the hands of the
medici
uh it's beset by factional um divides
and the whole of italy is in uh the grip
of
of a very complex series of wars
it's evident that machiavelli needs a
job and to get a job he needs to
persuade the medici
that he's a good advisor and to do that
he needs to show them how to stay in
power
within these circumstances and that's
why he suggests
uh being uh you know uh
cruel dishonest et cetera when necessary
i should stress
um but the work is written in a
deliberately discreet and subtle way
i really knew very well that he couldn't
simply say to the medici
um hi i'd like a job here's what i think
about your situation
so he dresses it up in a very abstract
way as if he's
writing a very disinterested piece of
political philosophy
and that has made it very easy for
people from soon after
it was written to read it um
in out of its context if i can put it
that way
to see it as a repository of universal
ideas rather than an attempt to address
very precise concerns and the problem i
mean that's a legitimate way of reading
anything i'm not going to
cast aspersions on my colleagues in
political science no matter what i might
feel
um but as soon as you take that step of
reading it
out of its context um then
there's a tendency or a temptation i
should say to project your
a historical reading of the prince back
onto machiavelli
and that does lead us to
misrepresent his ideas his background
his intentions what was his personality
like
it seems like someone who would have we
would write this sort of stuff
would be very game playing you know high
on the dark triad score
narcissistic no empathy
what sort of a man can write this sort
of a work
um well the short time is a clever one
but a pleasant one
if i were to describe machiavelli in a
word i would say that he was a bit of a
lad
um that that's
that three that three letter words that
every university student rugby player
desires to be called
that's that's nicole or machiavelli well
i i i say a little bit in jess of course
but
it is meant seriously because
i mean let's go back to the
circumstances in which it was written
it the prince was written because it's a
good insight in the type into the type
of guy he was
a little bit before he uh is
he loses a job he loses his job as a
senior bureaucrat within the florentine
government because
he has aligned himself with um it says
republican
uh assist a republican system of
government um
and um afterwards foolishly
uh allowed himself to get caught up in
or implicated in a conspiracy against
france's new world is the medicine
so he gets arrested off that and thrown
into prison and tortured
um that shows straight off that he's
in the wrong place at the right time at
the wrong time other
bureaucrats who worked in the same
office as him
such as his boss marco uh
did not lose their jobs let alone get
thrown into jail
so he's doing the wrong thing while he's
in jail he writes a series of poems two
poems to his old friend juliana dominic
who we knew as a kid and these are very
very very funny verses for somebody
who's been tortured lying in a stinking
prison cell
they're very amusing um they
followed himself he votes for it himself
he
contrasts himself he adopts the form of
heroic
poetry at certain moments to mock
himself because he's not being heroic
he's been karaoke eventually he gets let
out
and because he doesn't have much cash
and he's very miserable
he goes to stand his farm in the
countryside in the countryside
uh he writes a letter to um to a friend
of his little bit later
which he described a difficult day what
does he do in the countryside well
he gets up in the morning he goes and
catches birds in the
in the countryside uh by the side of a
river and in the fields
he reads some poetry all very nice then
comes lunch he goes home
has a bite to eat and in the afternoon
he goes to the pub
uh in the local village there he
gambles and drinks with all the good for
nothings
his words and they you know they get
drunk and they have fights or whatever
he's not quite about this he's quite
open what he doesn't mention in that
letter is that
a little bit late he also he has let
several children at this point he's
married
he also has an affair with uh with a
localish girl
one of many affairs he had and then
later in the evening when
everything's kind of settled down he
goes into his study and he puts on
the clothes of the court
and he starts to read and write so in
that moment we can see all the rich very
human contradictions and failings of of
of this man
um he is very very clever um but he also
you know he likes a drink he has affairs
he's
he's a bit of a lad uh what can i say he
has affairs with both men
and women right he's got tons of kids
he's got a wife that loves him and it
seems like he loves too
but he's also uh spraying it around
for once one of a better word yeah
that's absolutely right
um he certainly has a lot of affairs
with uh with other women
um he uh some of them are very very
intense affairs
um so towards the end of his life he has
a
long long affair with a woman 20 odd
years i think 20
years his junior called and he writes
again a lot of poems to her that uh that
are very self mocking very
acutely aware of his own failings indeed
in one prayer he even seems to allude
to the fact that he may have been
suffering some elective dysfunction at
the time
um we think he also had some uh
relations with guys too
there's a little bit of uncertainty here
um but
i think there's probably enough evidence
that it
that we can that we can be pretty sure
about it um
but it's unusual at the time well
officially homosexuality and all
homosexual relations are uh
illegal um although there is a certain
ambiguity in the legislation
but nonetheless it is quite common um
under the radar effectively so he's
certainly not
not strange not not out of the order in
that regard
what are some of the other big
catastrophes that he goes through i want
to get into his
philosophy and his successes in a bit
but it seems like he has a nice litany
of things that
go wrong he's in the wrong place at the
wrong time and he seems to have a knack
for being able to do that
sure um well one of the important parts
of machiavelli's
uh job uh as a bureaucrat is the second
chancellor of the flanton republic
um was uh going on embassies
he was usually i mean i think on one
occasion towards the end of his life he
was actually an ambassador but on all
the other occasions
he was simply in a misery so in other
words he couldn't degree things on his
own
uh on the strength of his own name he
had to keep
working on the instructions of people
back home
um and to start with he's pretty bad at
this actually
we can't blame him too much because you
know he's
um his early missions uh he's still in
his late 20s
late 20s very early 30s um so he's never
done that kind of thing before but still
he is pretty naive
one of his first missions is to a woman
called catalina sports known as the
tigress of
and she is a formidable woman um
she's been holding uh or protecting the
defending
the independence of a little tiny state
uh in the midst of
near constant threats from all sides
anyway mackie billy goes long she has to
he has to secure a deal whereby uh
she'll let her
son who's a mercenary fight for florence
on similar terms and
he has to try to avoid giving away
too much on francis behalf and katherine
who's a wily old woman
she's not a wily woman um very well
educated
keeps sort of dropping hints she has to
drop hints because
um there are other people present at
these meetings
who can't be allowed to hear everything
so she keeps dropping hits and mackiely
just
doesn't notice just doesn't pick up on
them so she keeps having to send
her secretaries to you know have a word
with them and say you know what we're
really trying to say is this
pay attention anyway he gets a bit
better in time
but he he's in later missions he still
kind of misjudges the tone
so uh later he goes on a mission to
several missions the king of france and
uh the basic point of these missions is
to get the king of france who is
often um mounting expeditions to italy
uh in pursuit of his claims to the
kingdom of naples and to the dutch of
milan
to defend france against its enemies
anyway on one of these missions he has
to
um gain the favor of
[Music]
the king's chief minister josh don wise
and he catches george at one point
outside and
he says you know let me explain italian
politics
what kingly has to understand is this
you know this is a
guy in his mid-30s who has you know he's
not a fool
but he's lecturing one of europe's
foremost
political figures and georgetown listens
and he says uh yeah thanks
uh i don't need any lessons from you
chum jumps on his horse and rides off
anyway and it goes on like this uh
perhaps the most famous mission is where
he meets jesse borgia for the first time
uh this is in uh mid um
i think it's mid-1502 uh cesare borgia
the son of alexander sixth uh the pope
at the time he's trying to carve out a
state for himself in central italy
he's just captured a city called i've
been a beautiful beautiful city on a
higher high here a kind of plateau over
the towers above the the surrounding
countryside um
machiavelli and his uh companion uh
who is um a bishop arrive late at night
they
don't arrive when they're supposed to
they have to creep in through a back
gate
in the middle of a rainstorm and they're
caught by guards and they're dragged
before
cesarean soaking wet covered in mud in
the middle of the night having not even
managed to get into the city correctly
and machiavelli is just in awe in or of
chisering at that moment
and um that does cover
he gets over it quite quickly but but
that does kind of cover his relations
with jesus
more broadly speaking his political
errors um are
more fundamental and i've already
alluded to some of them um so for much
his political career
as a officially objective
in a political bureaucrat um
he just kind of does his job but in time
he aligns himself more and more and more
with um the defense of a republican
system of governance
and uh he becomes quite vehement
uh
10 15 11. and there's good reason for
that it's because the republic is under
threat from foreign attack but it wasn't
exactly the wrong
time to be doing that the wrong time to
be aligning himself with the public
because everything falls apart and the
medici come back and the republic falls
and as i've said he gets
sacked and and um spends a lot of time
trying to get a job with the medici
because he's not a rich man he needs to
work
um unfortunately uh he doesn't do very
well the prince
is written as i said earlier as a
journal application
um but when he comes to present the the
prince to the person who's dedicated
lorenzo the melody
um he comes the wrong time lorenzo has
just received a gift of two hunting dogs
from somebody else
and he doesn't even look at the book so
mackey really is
really angry and he goes off saying damn
these medici blah blah blah blah blah
anyway years later he eventually earns
their trust
and is sent on a few relatively minor
missions but
is involved in in uh their plans to the
their campaign to defend plants and
their enemies
and child you know you just wormed his
way back into their circle when
lo and behold they're kicked out of
florence as well
so he's again on the wrong side by then
however it's too late
and he dies sadly um
[Music]
uh rather disappointed so what's the
highest office that he gets to it seems
like he's
constantly selling
lows and buying highs and doing an awful
lot of work
to try and climb back up also
if you are listening somewhere beyond
the grave nikolo
i don't it sounds like such a turbulent
environment that it would have been very
difficult to have weathered those storms
that period would have been almost
impossible without the the foresight of
clairvoyance
um it wasn't impossible where people who
did manage to
weather the constitutional shifts in
florence without suffering too
much hardship in his boss for example
march
adriani who is just senior to him
uh stays in office as france's top
bureaucrat
um through um
through several changes of government
changes of regime at least
but you're right in saying that these
were very very very turbulent times
it was extremely hard to stay on your
feet um
it was hard enough for people of um
some wealth political independent
political standing but it was
it's even harder for somebody like
machiavelli who um
who came from a fairly modest background
he wasn't poor but nor was he here
nor was he rich by any stretch of
imagination um
who you know began life under a bit of a
shadow
because of his father's indebtedness and
possibly legitimacy etc
um he really had to to to work together
to get anything really um and that was
difficult um
there were various routes to achieve
security and stability from an
intelligent guy at the time
um it was not unusual for those who had
some education and literary ability to
seek the patronage of
more powerful rulers or more powerful
figures um
alternatively you could seek um the
office as a secretary or a chancellor as
machiavelli did but in that case
it was difficult to weather the storms
and it was difficult to know
when to involve yourself in the
political frame when not to
what are the most common misconceptions
about his
philosophical stances um well the most
common one
we've already touched upon um and that
is to say that machiavelli was a kind of
prophet
of if not evil certainly a morality
um this is a reading of the prince
that has been common from very shortly
after it
appeared in print it was never published
in his lifetime but it was it published
very shortly afterwards
um he was uh
you know attacked from both sides of the
confessional divide during the
reformation attacked by
catholics because they saw this as an
enemy of the virtuous worship they were
trying to defend
in the pre-trade time period it was
attacked by protestants who saw this as
an emblem of all the kind of
awful things that catholics were doing
um so
in france um many of your listeners may
perhaps be familiar
with some bartholomew's day massacre uh
in in france where
um on one particular knight on feasters
and bartholomew um
the protestants of paris
were butchered and those who survived um
often describe the the the the um the
king the king of france's actions
as very machiavelli so
uh that gives you a sense of the way in
which at the extent to which within a
few decades of his death he's already
become a kind of shorthand for
wickedness and evil
so was he he wasn't called immoral
during his own lifetime
because the work wasn't sufficiently
widely passed around for people to work
out what he was up to
well it it it was um it did generate a
bit of a stir
uh after he began circulating it but
nothing compared to what was hap what
happened in
later decades what do you think what do
you think he would have thought of that
what do you think he would have thought
of where his work was
taken after his death well this this is
um
an interesting question because it it it
comes back to the issue of where
for whom machiavelli was writing or who
he thought he was writing for
those who have been inclined to see him
as a prophet of immorality
have supposed that he was writing for
posterity
um uh leo strauss and harvey mansfield
have been particularly
um keen to uh advocate this line of
thought
now it wasn't uncommon for people at the
time to write for posterity
um one of machiavelli's favorite
authors was a guy called francesco
petrarco who we know in english as
petrarch
and he was you know incredibly important
poet second only the damn thing in
importance in fact
and he wrote during his lifetime in the
14th century a letter to austerity was
constantly re-editing his letters
to ensure that they were read in exactly
the way he wanted them to be read after
his death
he spoke frequently about um how it was
possible to sort of
have an existence beyond the grave uh
and he was always comparing himself to
people who
had an enduring legacy
but i don't think machiavelli was like
that i don't think he was writing for
posterity at all
he occasionally alludes to um
people in the future but it's always
very clear that he's writing for a
specific moment
against a very specific concept
background very specific constellation
of circumstances so i think
um each of his major works
was intended to address an immediate uh
objective the prince
was designed to respond to the
challenges facing the medici after they
returned to ban france in 1512.
the discourse see his other major work
uh was um dedicated to some of the
friends he made
in the orthodox gardens where he met
young men who were either a mixture of
people
on the periphery of the major circle or
those who were opposed in aging
and there is a suggestion that it's
intended to
cultivate a new set of political
sensibilities
uh in their hearts um i think he
probably
i think he probably would have been
surprised um
at uh the fact that that he has had such
an enduring
uh appeal that he had a readership
lasting you know five centuries on the
first day
do i think he would be surprised by that
his work was read as
um or misread his praise of
immorality or even immorality i'm not
sure about that because
he was very conscious of the extent to
which he was breaking with tradition
in the prince he was you know very very
well
he he signaled it himself so the answer
is i think
uh i think he he would have been both
surprised and surprised sorry that was a
typical historian
very diplomatic yeah indeed um back to
the misconceptions
um
in what sense i'm sorry the most common
misconceptions of his face
as i said the most common misconception
arises from the prince that he
is attempting to suggest that rulers who
wish to remain in power
should be um absolutely involved in all
in all circumstances um that
um as i said if you read it out of its
context then
you can make that argument um
but i'm not convinced it's it's
completely true because
in fairness if you actually read the
prince in detail um
he is very very careful to qualify these
you know kind of scare quotes as often
pulled out
um he says yeah i mean it's nice for
prince to be loved i mean
that's obviously that's what we should
should aim for
but if you can't then the next best
thing is to be feared
and wear doubt against the certainty um
however he also says that if you're
going to make yourself fear
be careful not to push that too far
because if you make
yourself into a monster then you're
going to arouse a whole bunch of of
animosity amongst
your your subjects and they're going to
to at some point
um decide that it's better to take the
risk of asking you
even though that is extremely uncertain
he says that's where then to remain
under your yoke
um he doesn't of course again say that
it is necessary always to
reject the precepts of a morality he
merely says
reject the precepts of conventional
matter he merely says that
a prince should know how to act contrary
to the dictates of conventional
morality when necessary um
and how to be virtuous in a new sense
virtuous
in the sense of being a man being manly
in his words
so yeah the common misconceptions uh
that's the most common misconception
um i i mean i
i think we can there are
it's perhaps worth noting that even
those who
who do present machiavelli as an
advocate of
a morality or a prophet of evil if you
like
um have difficulties in reconciling the
prince with some of his other works
which
offer a somewhat different view of
political action
like the discovery for example um
the discourse is uh nominally a um
an explanation of how one should read
the
first 10 books of libya's history of
rome
but in actual fact is an analysis of how
states
of all kinds not just principalities um
become great and stay great and that
ends up
the answer to that is that they have to
stay free in his words because you can't
be great unless you're free
so the question is how do you become
free and keep your your liberty
and the answer is once again virtue um
[Music]
obviously virtually not in the
traditional sense but virtue in the
sense of being willing to do anything
for the defense of the republic being
uh to veer willing to sacrifice even
yourself
uh in defense of the public willingness
to as like everybody says
kill rape steal whatever necessary
to protect the public and then he talks
about the way in which you can cultivate
that virtue because
people tend to be self-interested the
more in fact the more prosperous people
become he says
but the more likely they are to think
only of themselves so the question is
how to cultivate this virtue
in the people more generally um and
as though he does return to some of the
ideas he uh
he made in the he raised in the prince
um such as that leaders charismatic
leadership is an important
um means of contributing virtue into
people and charismatic leaders
uh should occasionally be quite cruel he
doesn't suggest that it's the beyond
endor um in
in fact he it just introduces a whole
range of other ideas
like the need to eliminate great
disparities of wealth um the need to use
it all as a form of education
um the need to cultivate a vigorous
religious belief uh et cetera et cetera
so um
the the the the challenge for people who
have read the prince as a defense of
um uh princely uh
rulership i've often struggled to
to explain how the prince uh
tesselates with with this courtesy which
is seems ostensibly to be more concerned
with republics and
other forms of governance um
and it's challenging it's challenging
for those who
see machiavelli as this prophet of evil
because
um if you read it out of context it can
appear that
he's advancing to completely
contradictory viewpoints
whereas the reality is a he's writing in
response to different circles slightly
different circumstances for slightly
different audiences
and also in the context um
the problem which the problems which
he's addressing are essentially
identical
um in the 16th century um there is less
of a sense
of a radical uh difference
between princely and republican senses
forms of government much less pronounced
than we we think today
um so in actual fact all he's trying to
do is
ask the question of how does a state of
any kind
ruled in whatever way um maintain some
kind of stability
in this mad and changing world where
fortune
can you know do whatever she likes
it seems interesting to me that he is
being held up
by many people as a
philosophical political philosophical
prophet in one way
and yet in his own deployment of these
strategies
appears to fail quite consistently i
mean he does okay but he's
he doesn't seem to have the foresight
that he's professing others should take
on
he doesn't have foresight but what he
does have is an extraordinary sense of
self-honesty
um he is not a sort of person who is
um unwilling to recognize where he's
gone wrong
or so you know
arrogant that he cannot see fault
in his closest allies and dearest
friends
so in um
the disclosure for example he
takes issue with his former boss um
the head of the of of the republic uh
with which
which he served so loyally for for 13
years
uh 13-bit years um a man called
um is is
castigated quite quite severely in the
discourse
um for admittedly not for the worst
thing of the world but for being too
kind
and being too nice and being unwilling
to
um uh act ruthlessly towards his
his opponents um but nonetheless this
is evidence of somebody who's willing to
question
um his previous experiences and indeed
he makes this very clear
um both in the in the prince and in this
course he says you know i've been around
a bit i've seen
things and here's what i've learned
yeah and indeed this is really the
things he's with this is something that
comes time and time again in his other
works uh at around the same time he's
writing these books he also writes a
note to
um uh somebody who's about to go away
uh on his first diplomatic mission and
machiavelli says
these are this is the stuff i've learned
uh
take heed he doesn't say he's always got
it right indeed he's
aware that he's often that from his own
errors
um but there it is what are some of the
main
lessons that we should take away
um it's very difficult to to answer that
because
it kind of invites um an answer which
uh which which commits the kind of a
historical scene that i have criticized
already
but let's play the game anyway um
i think
i think two serious ones and one less
serious one
a central theme running through all of
machiavelli's writings
uh is fortune and the vicissitudes of
fortune
fortune he says is what rules the world
around us uh but
she it's always he always imagines her
as a woman
she is very unpredictable and very
capricious
you never know when uh she's going to
rise you up to the highest heights
when she's going to knock you down on
your knees she can't be won over he says
she's not gonna be placated
with uh implications she's not gonna
duplicate it with
uh you know virtue anything like that
you you are not going to be able to
affect her
her decisions so the only thing you can
do
is be ready to adapt to be changeable to
be flexible
and when the moment comes not to be
timid to act decisively when necessary
and that i think is um one but one of
the very f
he first voices that in relation to um a
pope julius ii who he admires
for a time for his decisive action but
it is one of the very few points that
you can
abstract as a kind of universal
principle and i think
is one which we can all apply to a
certain extent in our lives particularly
at the moment of instability such as now
the second one perhaps is um a little
bit historical but not too ah historical
um in many of machiavelli's works
he displays an acute awareness
of a um that
the florentine state and in all polities
are weakened by great disparities of
wealth
uh in florence uh since very early times
um society's been divided between two
groups uh
the uh the uh the puffballer
um and the the grassy the the people and
the fat cats if you like this is a
rather simplistic way of looking at
planting society but it's not invalid
it's pretty pretty okay as a model for
looking at it and he says this is
problematic because each of these two
groups
has totally opposed objectives
the the fat cats um the oligarchs they
want
to dominate and the buffalo
want not to be dominated
now obviously we're not all living in
15th 16th century florence
uh and the circumstances
enjoyed by experience for each of these
groups is not duplicated today but
it is true that in today's political
environment we do see
great disparities of wealth creating a
series of political problems
um you know if governments
which are obliged to look at almost any
area either a fiscal policy or social
policy
are obliged to um particularly at
a point such as now when we are
recovering from a terrible economic
shock
of how to balance the interests of these
two groups
and um machiavelli obviously says you
know
if you you can't can please both of them
that's funky dory
um but he also says that um
on balance uh it is better
to stick with the um
the the the the the have-nots
um for a variety of reasons today as i
won't go into at the moment
and that i you know you people might
disagree with that but nonetheless
i do think his analysis of um
is his contention that disparities of
wealth constitute a major problem for
any polity wishing to establish
stability remains true today as it has
always done
the less serious point is this
actually as you said it was off getting
things wrong it was always the wrong
place at the wrong time
and he often got very depressed he
he was quite frank about that in his
voluminous correspondence he often
said how there he was and how miserable
he was
but he always bounces back he always
keeps a smile on his face he's always
joking and laughing
and that i think is
is reassuring um
i think it's reassuring because
when we think of somebody like
machiavelli you know it's a name that
ranks alongside
startled blade though marx hegel etc in
importance
but knowing that he was a very human
chap who got down who had a laugh etc
i think it's somehow i don't want to say
inspirational but
it
it makes it seem as if these olympian
figures aren't
so far beyond our reach i really like
that
i spent my last birthday last year
in athens walking around the agora and
the store pour iklay
and then the year before that in the
roman forum walking around the coliseum
and
and the sistine chapel so for two
birthdays in a row until covert came in
and spoiled it all um i was adding
context to things that i'd learned and
read
and i think i had undervalued
how much that contributes to a greater
deeper understanding it's only really
when you can feel what and i i hope to
go to florence so
i would have gone this year that would
probably be my birthday this year had
traveled not being
restricted and i want to walk around the
streets and i want to think and and feel
and you know have an audiobook
on kindle with me or whatever and um
yeah i i understand what you mean i
think that by humanizing these figures
it makes their achievements feel
closer it makes them seem more mortal it
reminds us
that they're not performative figures
although the performative nature of
the the prince is particularly like
funny i suppose
in terms of a mirroring here but they're
not just performative figures they're
not these celebrities
like wwe wrestlers you know they kind of
feel a little bit like that
larger than life they they
become caricatures of themselves and we
see this with machiavelli's work
absolutely and to hear that he's just a
man who has
sometimes doesn't get it up for his
misses and he goes and gets in fights
not his misses not his listen okay it's
mistress sorry yes no you got it
made sure that you performed for the
misses you've got to do that if you're
going to cheat on your at least perform
when you get your hands on it
um yeah i just thought i i think that's
really that's really right but that's
the thing that
that strikes me as why
people are tending to misread
his work especially when they don't view
it in the wider context
because they don't understand just how
performative it was that it was written
as this thinly veiled low-key job
application
with a very specific set of of
parameters for the person he was trying
to write it for
and presumably as well if you're doing
that for essentially one person or one
group of people
you're not intending for it to be still
read half a millennium later
and published to the entire world to see
so it makes sense why people are
misrepresenting that or at least
misunderstanding or misinterpreting it
i would put a writer on that actually um
i
i agree with everything you say
absolutely
um but i i don't want to suggest that
there is only one way of reading the
prince
at all the great benefit of placing
machiavelli in his context
and humanizing him uh and recognizing
that his
prince and all his other works written
against a basic specific set of
circumstances
is important not because i think that
necessarily leads you to a true
understanding of it although
i have my own opinion of it and if i
didn't think it was right i wouldn't
have written with the biography but
i think by humanizing any uh political
philosopher
it becomes easier to engage with their
works
at a meaningful substantive level
critically
rather than viewing them as works of
some olympian genius
far beyond our reach or you know
our humble experiences but as
the scribblings of someone who was
troubled or having difficulties or
whatever
we can you know effectively
talk to them i mean like cicero said of
his books you know you talk to talk to
your books
um you criticize them you challenge them
and maybe you produce something outside
of it
of your own and that i think is is much
more valuable and a much more
useful um way of reading
uh political philosophy whether it be
imaginability or somebody else's
than simply looking at it as
reading it as a passive uh consumer
what do you disagree with most talking
about criticism and
and pushback what do you degree uh
disagree with most
that was in machiavelli's work or
assumptions that he held about the world
or
philosophy at large
what do i disagree with um one of the
reasons i haven't given a creative
thought that i should confess is because
i
actually find his lesser works much more
exciting i really like his poems and his
plays and
uh they're very funny you can't really
disagree with the play can you
just say you just say it's [ __ ] or good
that's that's through the spectrum
yeah yes yeah i think there's some
literary critics who might disagree with
that
but yes yes essentially um but there are
little problems um
i think uh what would i disagree with
um i think there are some um
there are many aspects of his uh works
which do not necessarily interpret his
own times in an accurate way
um so for example his tremendous faith
in a citizen army
which is one of the the most important
points he makes
uh in the prince that is courtesy and in
the um the art of war above all
um he was very keen on this uh because
partly because he had we helped
re-establish a citizen militia in
florence can you just explain what a
citizen
army is sorry of course at the time it
was
common for states like florence to uh
not have a standing army of their own
instead they employed mercenaries
often dozens of mercenaries each with
a couple of you know 20 or so horsemen
uh knights soldiers whatever under their
command and cobbled together an army in
this kind of imperfect way and these
were
hugely unreliable um they were these are
these just pay to play guys yeah they
were exactly
um you paid these guys to fight on your
behalf they worked for the highest
bidder
um they were necessary um predominantly
because walls were becoming
uh bigger in scale and more
professionalized with
more expensive equipment like cannons
uh crossbows uh rudimentary firearms
etcetera so you needed professionals
and these guys had a professionalism in
spades but because they were working for
money
um you couldn't always guarantee that
they weren't going to betray you
too yeah or just not fight in the end or
whatever
um so machiavelli argues uh vigorously
throughout his life for a citizen
militia what does that mean that means
your own citizens fight for you nowadays
this seems like a very obvious idea
and indeed many modern states have made
this the absolute cornerstone of their
existence
the um uh america for example you know
the right to bear arms
is absolutely fundamental to american
existence
uh and the idea of fighting uh for your
your your nation uh in defending its
liberty is
you know axiomatic um but for mackie but
it was very new
and he gives the impression that any
state that does
has a citizen army uh is going to be
stronger than one with a bunch of
mercenaries
except that at the time that just wasn't
true
um florence develops under his
uh um oversight a citizen militia
and it may have had contributed a bit
to some successes like the recapture of
pisa but when push comes to shove and it
really has to show its mettle
it doesn't live up to expectations at
all
um when in 1512 um florence is attacked
by an enormous
uh spanish papal army and um the militia
is basically anything that's
there standing between florence
and and this crisis
and they're locked in a place um called
prata not not
not far away and they just don't do
anything they don't do anything
um he repeatedly despised he repeatedly
argues for it in other contexts
um uh he tries to persuade the pope to
set up a
militia in romania but it's not going to
happen
it needs an apparatus that's completely
different why is he wrong well
that's a different argument altogether i
think it was basically because it was
too small
and he wasn't well enough trained and
then he does talk about training
um but uh that i think
he got wrong and that was in fact kind
of recognized
by by um by many of
the early readers of the art of war um
he
his view of military tactics his
view of mercy of his view of mercury's
etc is he
doesn't enjoy a great deal of popularity
by readers of the article although it is
hugely hugely popular as a book
um instead readers are more interested
in his um his
view of uh you know vertu or whatever
so what i disagree with that as a
reading of how to fight a war in the
16th century
nice idea doesn't work in practice i
like it what are some of your favorite
stories from him you've got him turning
up to as an emissary
covered in mud sneaking in through the
back door are there any other favorite
stories you've got of his
um there's lots
many of which aren't suitable for a
family audience this isn't a family
audience don't worry alex this is a
this is a very mature audience and it's
got the explicit rating on itunes so
you're good to go
to hear that um well it's an absolutely
horrible story actually
of when he's uh late in his his uh his
career as second chancellor france he is
sent to deliver a bunch of cash to the
emperor
in northern italy and while he's on his
way back he uh experiences
um what he calls conjugal famine
which means he hasn't had sex for a
while he's getting rounded conjugal
[Laughter]
anyway and he's walking back home
and one day and obviously staying
there's a there's
an old lady who does his shirts from who
he does his laundry room
and she approaches him and says uh hey
sir uh can i interest you in in anything
and uh and she says i think i have
something that might appeal to you in
the cellar
or in it down in my place and so he
follows her
and um he uh she pulls back a curtain to
reveal
this um a um
prostitute uh sitting on a bed and he
the light's very dim and he doesn't
really think she's she's very attractive
and
her breath stinks a bit and it's not
very big but he's
so randy that he thinks what the hell
anyway so the inevitable happens
and uh then when he's done
um he thinks i i think i better
better take a look at this lady so he
pulls the light
closer and the description he gives is
just just awful
poor woman you feel so sorry for her he
said no
it's it's just horrible and anyway it's
i won't guarantee you but
it's so disgusting that he is sick all
over
oh that's bad and then he runs out
um it's a horrible story it's a horrible
horrible story
but that is kind of the guy he was um
i think it's um
he i've already mentioned how much i
like his poems and plays but
but these are the repositories of of
really lovely stories
that may not necessarily have been
indebted to his his life but will
certainly
reflect he's like but he's only indebted
to some of his experiences
um so for example he writes a play
called the uh the mandragola um
where i won't give you too much detail
because i know time's getting on but
basically um a student who just come
back from paris has heard about this
really attractive lady
um and he wants to see if she's as
beautiful as um
as everyone says and it turns out she's
even more gorgeous
the problem is she's married to an old
fuddy-duddy of a lawyer who's a bit a
bit dim
anyway he decides that he's got to
seduce her
and so he enlists the support of uh good
for nothing
um and they consider all kinds of
different plans of
how to how how you can get into bed with
her and he eventually
hit upon an idea which is to say that um
this couple
um have long wanted a child but have
never been able to conceive
and so our hero dresses himself up as a
doctor
and offers them a solution which is um
uh uh a potion made from a mandrake root
make whatever that what you like and he
says drink this as soon as you drink
this you will conceive
but there's a catch there's a catch the
first person to sleep
with you lady wife um after you drink
this
will die so obviously it can't be your
husband
so his accomplice
uh suggests uh a way around this
this threat which is to say that they
will kidnap somebody who will
draw out the poison and save the husband
from the
the danger and inevitably it's the same
guy as the student
and uh he allows us to be kidnapped he
sleeps with this woman and she's
you know eventually he reveals himself
and she's so happy with it they carry on
their affair
and how the husband thinks this is you
know thinks that he's been saved
so he's hugely grateful and blah blah so
you know another awful
um sexual story i suppose um but it's
that kind of body humor is very very
emblematic of of machiavelli's way of
looking at the world and his life
um he
it's interesting that in that story we
would expect
him to project himself onto the students
but actually it isn't the case um the
husband whom he girls is called
messenicia and there are lots of reasons
why he's called nikki
but one of them could be that it sounds
very similar to
so in actual fact he's putting himself
in the position of somebody who is
trapped
um and again that's evidence of his
you know his willingness to laugh at
himself so
there you go there are lots of other
stories as well which i won't go into
but
if you haven't read them they're a
little bit difficult to find but but
they're really worth reading they
all hilarious the blaze and the air and
the the bones
it seems like he's got his unique weapon
is his metacognizance it's his ability
to think about thinking and to see where
he stands within
the movement of things he's obviously
able to watch human nature
and perceive it even if he's not able to
deploy the skills required to manipulate
it himself
he's obviously very perceptive and even
perceptive of himself
and his own failings
which yeah i mean when you hear these
sort of stories about someone that
you know is a titan of the renaissance
um
yeah it really does it really does
humanize them in in quite a sort of
endearing
way yeah exactly he he you're right in
saying that his self-awareness
and his awareness of his place in his
times is
extraordinary his greatest strength yet
in a funny way also perhaps
reflective of his greatest weakness at
the same time and
you know very very endearing i'm not
saying that
everyone should aspire to be like
machiavelli in his private life
let's be clear about that because he was
an absolute rotter
he was a fiend not a fiend in the way
that we think of but he was uh
he was as alan clark's wife said he was
an sh-1t
and yeah he was i'm not saying he's a
model but he's certainly more endearing
more human more fallible um
i think one of the reasons that i i
enjoyed writing this biography more than
almost any other book i've written
is because i found it much easier to
relate
to somebody fallible than to
somebody who had taken great care to
craft their image blah blah blah
now you know we've all we've all have
not setbacks we've all
taken a a blow or two from fortune
maybe not the same kind but it's much
easier to empathize with someone of
their nature
that's why i'm doing writing and why i
hope people enjoy reading the biography
i think that they will do alex i really
enjoyed this machiavelli his life and
times
in brand new paperback edition will be
linked in the show notes below
is there anything else that you want to
plug any other places people should go
to check out your stuff
um uh there's another uh
book i wrote a little while ago called
the ugly renaissance sex disease in
excess in an age of beauty
which explores some of the um ex
you know hidden backstories behind the
great after renaissance
uh the cd uh underside of of the the
renaissance belly if i can put it that
way so if you like the
the the naughty a bits of lucky but he's
like that's a another place that you you
might like to turn
perfect i love it alex thank you very
much thanks so much alexis
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that then press here
for a selection of the best clips from
the podcast over the last few months
and don't forget to subscribe it makes
me very happy indeed
peace